[Applause]  [Applause]  yesterday  moments like moments ago here you are  don't please of course  so really just I came which dream last  night jumped on a plane came here this  morning to say not dangling I'm doing  and couldn't be happier with the way  everything's always super amazing just  the talent and the sense of the suspects  and everything is going to basically  well and I couldn't be happier  you know I normally do companies things  day  [Applause]  [Applause]  - retrieves back  it's a  [Applause]  I brought these two glasses  a person  [Applause]  knocking microphones I'm afraid you guys  have some questions do we think I'm not  going to take a picture of this year  [Applause]  [Applause]  you  you